hello what hi how's it going my name is
markiplier and welcome to the whisper
challenge if you don't know what the
whisper challenge is he's gonna whisper
comes for the other three participants
of listening to very loud as in
Hampshire Webb saying so I read the clip
and then whispered very quietly to them
they try to read my lips and interpret
what I'm saying and then pass that on to
the next person like he didn't know for
obviously hole where it says four words
and then we're gonna see what it really
was when it's over huh anyway you guys
ready don't we don't forget the screen
shut we yes we've got suggestions here
from you guys on hashtag big cranberries
because that's what we need for this
Thanksgiving holiday that is probably
after Thanksgiving by the time you see
this never mind me big old dumb moisture
Mar mark bar must room mushroom arts
your your songs at a faster tempo than
mine I do have great packs penguins are
the only thing I don't have
penguins are the only thing I don't have
penguins don't choose the pancake life
penguins going to the pancake life okay
all right what is it
put back those shoes it's the pancake
life are you as if penguins don't choose
the pancake life okay
penguins are the only thing I don't have
somebody once told me the world is my
home
oh wait I know what it is yeah but you
can't say that somebody once told me the
world is my home someone once told me
the world is my oyster no what I said
was somebody once told me the world is
my homey somebody once told me the world
is gonna roll me I ain't a shop is doing
- sure don't sing it angers the
capybaras don't sing it angers the
capybaras Tony Hawk once sold me some
applesauce Tony Hawk once sold me some
applesauce
so mark would you get jerking off in a
barrel of applesauce that was like word
for Tony Hawk once sold me some
applesauce is what I said we was don't
sing it angers the capybaras Oh hair the
power boots the hair hope our food is
fuel for the Power Rangers food is fuel
for the Power Rangers oh so what I heard
what I heard before fisting
before fisting the power always so close
food is fuel for the power okay
loose the hair for power mark is the
ultimate dabbing king mark is the
ultimate dabbing can burn the clothespin
anemone burn the clothes came anemone oh
shoot
I don't know what put the zucchini on me
no I said burn the clothespin anemone
I'm gonna check the arisen because I've
I said mark is the ultimate dabbing King
oh yeah
anemone dabbing king grabbing King kind
of no zucchini is closer to dabbing the
name and then anemone anemone zucchini I
could definitely see but my goodness
Dobby has no master Dobby is a free elf
can you talk normal for once Dobby has
no master Dobby is a free elf but is so
long no again stop asking your master
when you can go out with me it's so fast
stop asking your master when you can go
out with I got this one on lock you can
put my ass in your pants and turn around
and beat me that what you said no stop
asking your master when you can go out
with me oh I think I'm pretty close okay
and the real tweet was Dobby has no
master Dobby is a free elf oh I got
master
I didn't get any put your ass in my
pants let's make some gingerbread man
let's make some gingerbread men like
although you're one more cuz I cannot be
right on this one boy please don't make
me say what I think you said okay let's
make some gingerbread men
I swear I'm trying to get anything else
but what I think you said lesbians have
a machine powered Ian's have [ __ ] power
is another one I said Wow lesbians ever
machine power penis the real thing is
please be closer let's make some
gingerbread men I don't know I ever knew
it for hire Cooper picked his poopy
poopy pants Peter Cooper picked his
puffy poopy Peter Cooper picked his
puffy poopy pants Peter Cooper picked is
puffy poopy pants
Peter Piper's pup puffer penguins pooped
my pants close he nailed it nailed that
the rabbits ever happen yes well we both
said the Xindi peter pooper picked his
puffy poopy pants yes wow that was good
oh all right really God's good not funny
we're good that's real good why are
there so many
Bilbo's why are there so many
Bilbo's why are there so many people why
are there so many people why are there
so many people why are there so many
short people why are there so many
people oh why are there so many Bilbo's
oh we closed three way i five robe will
be a white beard Sam Sam Sam put it in
my robo
my mac and cheese
screams when I eat it we're off to a bad
start my mac and cheese screams when I
eat it I'm not trying to do you told me
to pick ones that are tough my penis is
struggling to contain its girth do that
again my business is struggling to
contain it maybe it's time for you to
increase your girth my penis is
struggling to contain it to girth oh I'm
guessing that wasn't close at all my mac
and cheese screams when I eat it
not even close not even close it'll go
up to the edge of the camera and
silently say that line
see the advantages you know what it was
before but it cut it so they I really
like the actor bendy dick come and snap
don't you that one thing okay go again I
really like you actor baby dick coming
snap don't you
I really like the ass demolisher don't
you close it got close yeah I really
like the ass demolisher don't you I like
eating basketball shorts don't you
I like the ass demolisher don't you
I really like the actor bendy dick
Cummings nah don't you you like bendy
dick come and snap are you looking at
this one there some recording this
oh god no they're recording us big moist
is the opposite of small dry why are you
picking long ones big moist is the
opposite of small dry big boys are the
opposite of small kids
your lips are impossible to rain cuz
everytime I see penis everytime when I
look at your lips I see penis big boys
are the opposite of small kids alright
penis pump or the opposite of Chipotle
baby boy those big boys are the opposite
of small kids real tweet
big moist is the opposite of small dry I
got really close guys close I had the
middle part was your room mouth I got
chicken ah that was me that was the
whisper challenge we were doing one more
on my ended now cuz my god
remember where we stood I like chica wig
wag just Bigsby look so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to see more of this let us know it
just ends up it was like the predominant
subject in our conversations it is
haunted dead pity there's a lot of dick
savers okay so thanks again everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought or us note down the description
below
we're comments if you want a description
down there somewhere to start writing on
your monitor down below and we'll see oh
yeah Ethan's channel and then Tyler's
Twitter's in the description so thanks
again everybody for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next one
video how many times have I been doing
that outro how many and as always we
will see you in the next video bye bye
why